[Música]
qué escenario nos espera
en un futuro cercano en donde
próximamente seremos 10.000 millones de
personas
la población no deja de crecer generando
nuevas demandas energéticas
el informe de la situación mundial de
las energías renovables nos habla que el
73.8 por ciento de la demanda de energía
a nivel del mundo se cubre con energías
no convencionales y apenas es el 26.2
por ciento que se cubre con energías
renovables este pequeño porcentaje
forman parte de las centrales
hidroeléctricas las de eólicas las
fotovoltaicas las de biomasa y geotermia
pero como ustedes se pueden dar cuenta
es apenas una pequeña parte en la cual
ha logrado insertar
todos hemos escuchado acerca del cambio
climático todos hablamos del cambio
climático que es ocasionado por las
emisiones descontroladas de dióxido de
carbono y que ocasionan olas de calor
que ocasionan sequías y también
inundaciones pero sobre todo estas esto
esta emisión del co2 se da en industria
en la silvicultura en el transporte y
también en la producción de energía
eléctrica
como abastecer la demanda actual sin
tener que incrementar la producción de
energía a través del combustible fósil
hoy por hoy sabemos que conforme está
nuestro sistema energético tenemos que
emplear estos combustibles fósiles
estos son combustibles finitos estos
combustibles finitos como en el caso del
petróleo en donde ha llegado al cenit es
decir ha llegado a la tasa máxima de
explotación y de ahora en adelante la
producción comienza a bajar y sus costos
son elevados
en el mismo sentido pero en un horizonte
más largo de tiempo el gas natural el
carbón y el uranio también van a tender
a desaparecer
pero qué podemos hacer
acaso nosotros vamos a reducir nuestro
consumo energético hoy por hoy nuestra
sociedad de consumo nos lleva a tratar
de estar a la moda en todos los equipos
electrónicos de última tecnología
entonces la ciencia nos dice hay dos
caminos por recorrer y son simultáneos
el primero es el uso eficiente del
recurso y el segundo es incrementar la
producción de energía a través de
fuentes renovables
nos indican los científicos que el
crecimiento la tasa de crecimiento de
las energías renovables es del 2.6 por
ciento anual
en el mundo sin embargo la demanda el
consumo energético desmedido tiene un
crecimiento el 48% desde el año 2012 al
año 2040 es decir el crecimiento de las
energías renovables no van a poder
soportar la demanda mundial
qué podríamos hacer nuestro modelo
energético es uno de los principales
culpables para el tema del cambio
climático
el cambio climático que afecta
principalmente a las personas de más
escasos recursos económicos a los seres
vivos como los animales y a todo ente
viviente como hoy conocemos en nuestro
planeta
pero que podemos regresar a ver
nosotros podemos volver a verlo al sol
el sol es el primer responsable de que
exista vida en nuestro planeta aparte de
eso si no existiera el sol no habría
ningún tipo de energía renovable
toda la radiación solar el 46 por ciento
que puede absorber la tierra la
transforma en diferentes fuentes de
energía por ejemplo la transforma en
viento el sol no calienta de manera que
de igual manera todas las partes del
planeta tierra y esto provoca que esta
diferencia de temperatura haga que
recircula el viento y se produce la
energía eólica
de igual manera provoca un movimiento en
las olas del mar y tenemos la energía
mareomotriz y la undimotriz y si vemos
el aprovechamiento del calor del sol
tenemos la energía solar térmica y si se
transforma en luz tenemos la energía
fotovoltaica entonces si nosotros vemos
al sol podemos darnos cuenta que tenemos
una amplia gama de energías que aún no
hemos aprovechado o que todavía no ha
logrado insertarse en nuestra matriz
energética
pero yo les voy a hablar del viento
el viento como ustedes lo pueden ver en
esta en esta flor en esta hoja apenas el
0.7 por ciento de la radiación solar se
transforma en viento el viento es un
recurso inaceptable es decir es
renovable no es como los combustibles
fósiles que son finitos este es un
recurso realmente inagotable cuando lo
utilizamos para la producción de energía
eléctrica no emana gases al ambiente y
no produce elementos tóxicos y también
si analizamos a la fecha de hoy la
capacidad instalada en el mundo de
plantas eólicas hacen que se eviten
demandar de manar al ambiente 3 millones
de toneladas de co2 y otros gases
contaminantes
entonces podemos ver que este tipo de
plantas eólicas después de la energía
hidráulica son las plantas que mayor
producción de energía tiene
hasta aquí ustedes han podido ver un
análisis técnico unos datos estadísticos
unos criterios científicos sobre el
cambio climático sobre versión de las
energías renovables en nuestra matriz
energética pero en realidad detrás de
todo esto hay seres humanos
hay hombres y mujeres que trabajan en
esta parte en esta rama de la ingeniería
como es mi caso hace ya casi 15 años
abrace esta carrera en donde la vida me
dio la oportunidad de escoger un camino
hacia las energías limpias
este caso muy particular ustedes lo
pueden ver reflejado también en sus
profesiones o en sus futuras profesiones
en donde puedan escoger entre por
ejemplo hacer obras de construcción con
grandes afectaciones al sistema o al
ecosistema y pocas afectaciones
entre mi caso yo pude haber escogido
dedicarme a la energía nuclear
a la energía termoeléctrica en base a la
combustión del desierto de combustibles
fósiles o haberme dedicado a las
energías renovables y este amplio campo
ustedes lo pueden escoger en sus ramas
en sus carreras en su vida en donde
podamos decidir qué aporte puedo dar yo
no solamente en el aspecto científico
sino también como un legado de vida
todos somos parte de esta aldea global
en realidad es este nuestro hogar el
único que tenemos y si pensamos en un
verdadero legado de vida de un cambio
climático de un planeta que sea
sostenible este es el momento no se han
escuchado que ya estamos en el punto
cero en donde ya no hay marcha atrás
pues este es este es el momento este es
el llamado a que cada uno desde su
profesión desde su campo de acción pueda
dar un cambio hasta ese planeta que lo
necesitan
hay una frase que las quiero dejar a
ustedes somos suelo somos tierra lo que
le hacemos al suelo nos lo hacemos
nosotros mismos yo tomé una opción hacia
la parte renovable hacia la parte de la
energía limpia y les dejo a ustedes esa
misión de preguntarse cuál es su opción
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]